retro ret who are here guys in this past
week we finally got official
confirmation that the Wizarding World of
Harry Potter is getting even bigger
that's right guys a brand new theme park
expansion coming to Universal Orlando
and to someone who hasn't been able to
get down there since they added the
Diagon Alley section I absolutely cannot
wait for this but you want to know the
most exciting part we even have a few
reliable rumors on the major attractions
and guys it just sounds so incredibly
insane I if you can't tell I'm sorry my
height meter it's already at a level 10
here so in this video I'm going to get
you caught up on the top 10 things you
need to know about the new theme park
expansion to kick things off here we
have the official name of this section
of the park which will be the Wizarding
World of Harry Potter Ministry of magic
now this is not an addition to the
Diagon Alley or Hogs meet sections it
will actually be about 2 mies south of
Universal Studios and Islands of
Adventure it's part of a completely new
theme park called epic Universe set to
open sometime in 2025 now if you're
concerned as to whether they'll be able
to hit that Target date or not you
should know things are already well
underway we can actually see the
entrance to the ministry of magic
section already complete with the
circular portal and this whole portal
thing is a theme across all of the Epic
Universe areas on top there's a golden
statue of a hand holding what appears to
be the Elder Wand you can also see how
these shots compare to the concept artc
currently available on the official
website here we get a better look at the
text across the top of the portal which
features an iconic line from our
favorite Headmaster Alba Dumbledore for
in dreams we enter a world that is
entirely our own there's also what I'm
pretty sure is a Time Turner on on top
of the portal here if you've been to any
of the Potter theme parks before you'll
know that the attention to detail and
the respect to the lore is just
incredible here so I love the fact that
it's like we're taking a Time Turner as
we step into this world and I think
there's a very specific reason that we
need to travel back in time because not
only are we getting the ministry of
magic we're also getting Paris set in
the 1920s this time frame puts us
traveling here during the events of the
second fantastic Beast movie the crimes
of grindewald so essentially as you're
walking around the area everything will
look like Paris all the shops the
restaurants the interactive experiences
all of these will be themed to what we
see during this scene of crimes of
grindal this Paris section will also be
home to one of the two major attractions
in the new Wizarding World section
there's an indoor stage show positioned
here and it's expected to be a show
called lirk arcanis which is the name of
the traveling circus in the crimes of
grenald of course this is where we meet
Nini yeah if you didn't see fantastic
Beast this is actually Nini turns out
she's something called a maledictus and
then one of the most important
characters in fantastic Beast Credence
bebone so I'm super curious to see what
type of show that they will put on here
I mean it has to have Wizarding World
elements right it can't just be a
regular circus is it possible maybe
we'll even see nikini make an appearance
here the way it plays out in the movie
is that as kind of one of the biggest
moments of the show her actually
transforming into the snake now this
next one takes us a bit into rumor
territory because one of the things that
we might get to see in Paris at least
from the outside is the house of
Nicholas Fel of course fans know Fel
mostly as being the maker of the
philosopher Stone he also made an
appearance though in Fantastic Beasts he
offered his home to Dumbledore as a safe
house for allies working to take down
grindal so it seems as if this could be
one of the new areas that has a special
interaction when you're using wands sold
at the park now this is already a thing
in Islands of Adventure and Universal
Studios but there are a couple of
patents floating around out there that
makes it seem like the whole interactive
one experience is going to be getting an
upgrade in addition to these new
elements at this section of the park so
we got Paris Ministry of magic how exact
ly do these two connect because they're
not physically in the same place of
course well again it seems like they
definitely had the lore in mind here as
it's being reported we'll make our way
into the ministry via the flu Network
one of my favorite moments in the movies
is the first time we get to see the
British Ministry of Magic on the big
screen the amazing shots as Harry and Mr
Weasley step out into the massive Atrium
is such an iconic scene the Fountain of
magical Brethren oh man I can't wait to
actually see this in person of course
this is the scene where Mr Weasley
accompanies Harry to his trial after he
was charged with using Magic magic
outside of school as an underage wizard
now it's possible the only way to enter
the ministry will be through a line for
what is the feature attraction of this
whole area the ride inside of that world
I can't tell you because it has to be a
surprise and guys this is the most
exciting part for me yes while the
movies did a great job showing parts of
the ministry there was so much more that
we didn't get to see but now with this
standout attraction there's a chance
we'll get to see some of those areas as
well we don't have the official name of
the ride yet but there are some pretty
reliable rumors that it will be called
Harry Potter and the battle at the
ministry it's expected to feature ride
Vehicles similar to the elevators that
we see in the films you can expect a
combination of animatronics real sets
and giant wraparound screens and it's
not even expected to require 3D glasses
of course you know they got to have a
story play out as we go through this
ride and there was an early rumor that
the story would take place during a
trial for one Dolores UMD set after the
battle of Hogwarts as the trial is
taking place though Death Eaters break
in attempting to free Umbridge now lore
fans you guys will know this might be a
bit strange consider considering that
UMD was never a Death Eater that being
said I guess she did align herself with
them pretty closely in the final Potter
book and she certainly didn't seem to
have a problem with helping them when
they had taken over the ministry now I
think this could be interesting don't
get me wrong but if the name is actually
Harry Potter in the battle with the
ministry to me it would make way more
sense to have us play a role in The
Unforgettable battle during the climax
of Order of the Phoenix I mean can you
imagine getting a firsthand look at
dumore and Voldemort battling it out
with the giant fire and water spell
effects it would be absolute Insanity of
course if you're familiar with the story
lines on these rides they're usually
pretty laid-back pretty loose they don't
always follow a specific narrative from
the book they try to keep the lore in
mind but with the rides they always want
to make you feel like you're part of the
ride and like you're actually helping
out the characters so you definitely
have to bend things a little bit here
regardless of the actual story for the
ride though I really hope we get to see
some of those amazing areas in the
ministry in addition to the courtroom
area this is also the home for numerous
offices like the misuse of magic office
the or headquarters the Beast Division
and of course the department of
mysteries this is the one that I'm sorry
it it has to be included if you remember
from the books the department of
mysteries is home to seven different
areas including a room where time
behaves differently the Hall of Prophecy
there's the brain room and even the
death chamber which is the location of
the mysterious Veil that Sirius falls
through now it's probably unrealistic I
know that we'll get to see all of those
sections during a ride that's likely
just to be a few minutes but the patents
for the ride do give me hope that we
could see quite a few of them the
elevator itself should be able to move
both vertically horizontally and also
turn in any direction so we could
actually rotate between just a few real
world floors and directions but all of
the props and projections could swap out
as we move so with this there's
definitely a chance that we could get to
see quite a few of the ministry floors
in this ride now before we get to
another big rumor about what they might
be adding next to the Wizarding World
it's important to know it's not the only
new section here epic universe will also
be home to a gorgeous new land called
Celestial Park Dark Universe which will
be home to all of Universal's horror
creatures a How to Train Your Dragon
themed area which looks phenomenal and
for all my fellow Gamers out there Super
Nintendo World this one's going to
feature an augmented reality ride themed
to Mario Kart a Donkey Kong themed
coaster and a slower paac ride for the
little ones featuring Yoshi as far as
where you can actually stay there are
not one but three new hotels that will
be opening near epic Universe in fact
the grand Helios hotel which will have
500 guest rooms is actually located
inside the Epic Universe Park and as
someone who has been to Universal
Orlando before even though it will
definitely cost you more to stay on site
I think the benefits more than make up
for it the premier hotels there all
include free access to the Universal
Express Pass which basically lets you
skip the lines to some of the most
popular rides in the park now I do want
to point out we don't have the details
yet on how this will work specifically
with epic Universe I think you can
probably expect though that they're
going to have a similar system to what's
already in place for Universal Studios
and Islands of Adventure all right if
that's not enough for the Wizarding
World fans there are already rumors that
epic universe will see a new Wizarding
World Edition soon after the park opens
there's a pretty large area of land just
next to the ministry of magic section
and one of the early rumors again and I
have to stress rumor here so far a lot
of these rumors have actually ended up
being right but this one says that we'll
be taking flu powder yet again this time
though we're going to be transported
directly to Hogwarts into the Great Hall
here we would get to enjoy an elaborate
dining experience along with
storytelling elements that would wait
for it play out on the ceiling as you
dine like oh my goodness yes yes please
make this happen Universal and even
though this may be a little odd
considering that the Hogwarts Castle is
actually at the Islands of Adventure
section of the park hey you got to do
what you got to do right space is
limited because it's a magical world we
can use something like flu powder to
explain it perfectly in a lore accurate
way I love it and even though we are so
many years removed from the Harry Potter
series originally releasing the fandom
doesn't appear to be slowing down
anytime soon if you guys didn't hear a
Harry Potter TV show a reboot of the
original Seven book story is happening
and it's coming to Max formerly known as
HBO Max you didn't know that well guess
what I already got all the details that
you need to know right here check out
that video next guys thank you so much
for your support especially to our house
reck and tour members as always thank
you all so much for watching I'll talk
to you again soon